pues ustedes me pidieron que hiciera un
vídeo acerca de división polino miel
entonces vamos a hacer un vídeo acerca
de división polinomio digamos que
tenemos por aquí 2 x + 1
y queremos ver cuántas veces cabe este
polinomio dentro del polinomio
8x al cubo menos 7x cuadrada más 10 x
menos 5 aunque y entonces pues podemos
abusar un poquito de la notación que en
realidad no estamos abusando y tomar
este polinomio y meterlo dentro de la
típica casita de la división también
podríamos colocar por aquí una línea y
agarrar este polinomio y meterlo aquí
abajo como si fuera una fracción pero en
este vídeo vamos a usar un algoritmo muy
parecido de hecho casi idéntico al que
usamos siempre que ponemos un número
digamos
8 196 y le ponemos su casita y ponemos
por aquí otro número
ok recuerden en todo lo que hacemos
cuando estamos dividiendo números de
esta forma porque eso es justo lo que
vamos a hacer con estos polinomios bueno
vamos a empezar por borrar este número
que justo en el espacio que más voy a
ocupar
y empezamos a recordar todo ese
algoritmo si se acuerdan cuando tenemos
dos cifras en el número divisor lo que
hacíamos era tomar la cifra del grado
más grande o sea si pensamos en ésta
como las unidades y en ésta las decenas
entonces nos fijábamos en las decenas
que en este caso diríamos que es 2x y
veíamos cuántas veces que había en la
cifra de mayor grado de este número ok
aquí de este lado podríamos pensar que
estas son las unidades
decenas centenas y millares ok entonces
en realidad aquí lo que tenemos que ver
es cuántas veces cabe 2x dentro de 8x al
cubo y bueno para encontrar eso va a
saber poco a poco que esto se va a
volver de lo más natural que existe pero
por el momento lo más fácil es
escribirlo en algún otro lado por
ejemplo por aquí queremos ver cuántas
veces que haber 2x en 8 x al cubo o sea
que tenemos que tomar 8 x al cubo
y dividirlo entre dos equis y eso es
igual a haber ocho entre dos es cuatro y
equis al cubo entre x es equis cuadrada
ok entonces 2x cabe 4x cuadrada veces
dentro de 8x al cubo así es que lo que
tenemos que hacer es colocar este 4x
cuadrada en esta parte de la casita
ahora muy importante para no perder el
orden en estas divisiones
tenemos que colocar este 4x cuadrada en
el lugar de los x cuadrados aunque ellos
sea como por acá y vamos a poner 4x
cuadrado
ok porque recuerda que los x al cuadrado
son como las centenas a ver unidades
decenas centenas y no queremos poner a
las centenas en el lugar de los millares
entonces tenemos que colocarlo por acá
ahora lo que vamos a hacer es lo mismo
que cuando estamos dividiendo números
tomamos este término y lo multiplicamos
por todo este número o sea que nos queda
4x cuadrada por 2 x eso es 8 x al cubo
más 4 x al cuadrado por 1 o sea 4 x al
cuadrado y al igual que en la división
de dos números no se nos tiene que
olvidar que lo que queremos es a este
número todo este número restarle todo
este número entonces porque tenemos
menos 8 x al cubo y menos 4 x al
cuadrado
ok entonces
ahora si restamos y nos queda pues
obviamente estos dos términos se
cancelen y lo que nos queda es menos 7x
al cuadrado menos 4x al cuadrado que es
menos 11 x al cuadrado y pues aquí
estamos sumando les cero unidades y cero
decenas así es que éstos bajan tal cual
tal vez estoy exagerando con esta
anotación de unidades y decenas tal vez
en realidad deberíamos decir que no
estamos sumando ninguna constante y no
estamos sumando ningún término de orden
x a la 1 que bueno y aquí el algoritmo
se vuelve a repetir casi exactamente
igual tenemos que ver cuántas veces cabe
2 x + 1 dentro de este polinomio y
volvemos a hacer lo mismo nos fijamos en
el término de mayor grado que es 2x y en
este otro polinomio también nos fijamos
en el término de mayor grado - 11 x al
cuadrado y vemos cuántas veces cabe 2x
dentro de menos 11 x cuadrado y eso es
exactamente lo mismo que agarrar menos
11 x cuadrado y dividirlo entre 2 x
entonces hacemos esta división y nos
queda menos 11 medios podemos dejarlo
como una fracción y equis cuadrada entre
x es simplemente equis entonces vamos a
tomar este término y lo vamos a colocar
en el lugar de los x a la 1 que está por
aquí más o menos 11 medios d
y entonces tenemos que tomar este
término y multiplicarlo por 2 x + 1 y
nos queda haber 2x por menos 11 medios x
los 12 se cancelan y nos queda
simplemente menos 11 x al cuadrado y nos
falta sumarle más 1 por menos 11 medios
equis o sea menos 11 medios x ahora muy
importante a mí muchísimas veces se me
olvida por eso hago hincapié en esto
nosotros lo que tenemos que hacer es a
este polinomio restarle este polinomio
ok y hay dos opciones o te acuerdas de
que lo tienes que restar y multiplicar
este polinomio por menos uno y luego
sumas estos dos polinomios que ya me
gusta más la segunda pero es cuestión de
gustos cada quien tiene que hacer lo que
más le convenga yo voy a multiplicar
este polinomio por menos 1 entonces
menos x menos da más
y menos pero menos da más y ahora si
simplemente tenemos que sumar estos dos
polinomios menos 11 x cuadrada más 11 x
cuadrada es 0 y aquí tenemos 10 x + 11
medios de x eso es 31 medios por x y
como aquí no estamos sumando ninguna
constante podemos pensar que estamos
sumando un cero entonces nos quedan
menos 5 + 0 es un
-5 ok ya casi terminamos ya nada más nos
falta volver a hacer el algoritmo una
última vez y listo y tomamos el término
de mayor grado que es 2x y vemos cuántas
veces cabe 12 x dentro de 31 medios de x
gate 31 medios de x entre 2 x
la x se cancela con la equis y nos queda
31 cuartos
así es que colocamos por aquí el 31
cuartos en el lugar de las constantes y
multiplicamos 31 cuartos por todo este
polinomio y nos queda 31 cuartos por 2 x
eso es 31 medios x más 31 cuartos por 1
que es 31
cuartos y nos acordamos de que tenemos
que restar estos términos
31 medios x menos 31 medios x es un cero
más
menos 5 - 31 cuartos pues ahí lo que
tenemos que hacer es una suma de un
entero con una fracción menos 5 - 31
cuartos esto es igual a menos 20 - 31
cuartos y eso es igual a menos 51
cuartos aunque entonces ya terminamos 2
x + 1 cabe 4x cuadrada menos 11 medios x
más 31 cuatros veces dentro de 8 x al
cubo menos 7 x cuadrada más 10 x menos 5
pero deja un residuo de menos 51 cuartos
pues vamos a necesitar un poquito más
despacio
bueno pero en el fondo qué demonios
significa todo esto pues lo que
significa es que si tomamos este
polinomio 2 x + 1 y lo multiplicamos por
este otro polinomio que acabamos de
obtener que es 4 x al cuadrado menos 11
medios de x + 31 cuartos y además le
sumamos el residuo o sea menos 51
cuartos
entonces lo que obtenemos es este otro
polinomio great todo esto es igual a 8 x
al cubo menos 7 x al cuadrado más 10 x
menos 5
si queremos obtener este polinomio lo
único que tenemos que hacer es
multiplicar este polinomio por este
polinomio que acabamos de encontrar y
sumarle el residuo bueno espero que este
vídeo sea útil y nos vemos muy pronto